anthrax vaccinations for livestock one
of the ways herders in eastern ethiopia
can protect themselves against the
effects of climate change the disease is
much more of a threat during droughts
código one day is already struggling to
keep her animals alive through the
region's increasingly long and
unpredictable dry spells often during a
drought our animals can't find anything
to eat
sometimes when that happens we climb
into the trees to get them leaves during
the dry season we migrate to other
regions my wife and I had in different
directions
she takes the cows and I take the goats
that's how we survive the European Union
is funding this inoculation project
which is also training herders to give
their livestock medical attention it's
one of many measures EU commissioners
have undertaken to better equip some of
the people hardest hit by extreme
weather this is not the problem of the
future it has already been hammering
them day in and day arm and what we must
do is to help communities and especially
the poorest the most vulnerable people
to withstand this recurrent shocks for
EU climate Commissioner connie Hedegaard
the region's droughts represent a call
to action
I think that everyone who sees what the
Commission's are for people in the real
world they would agree that to handle
climate change that is an urgent
priority I know we are busy in Europe
handling our economic challenges but I
mean if you look at here we have some
other challenges as well one project
that the EU is funding is this
underground reservoir every drop of
rainwater stored here is one more tiny
victory in the battle against climate
change